hi everybody first of all I'd like to
thank Thermo for inviting me to talk to
you today about one of my favorite
subjects which is synthetic cannabinoids
um
over the next 20 minutes or so I'm going
to talk to you a little bit about
synthetic cannabinoid receptor agonists
give you some of the background to those
describe the analysis workflow that
we've set up here at LGC and then look
at some new compounds that we've been
detecting and some of the products
containing those new compounds
so synthetic cannabinoid receptor
agonists a brief history
in the mid 2000s there were rumors of
herbal smoking mixtures being sold
online as as legal highs that could
produce strong cannabis-like effects and
these were things that were called spice
as you can see some pictures of them at
the bottom of the screen
in in 2008
um the German and Austrian authorities
actually investigated some of these
products and identified something that
was uh called jwh 18 in one of these
products
in 2009
um we at uh LGC were contacted by a
long-standing friend of our lab a guy
called John Ramsey who was heading up a
company called Tic Tac Communications
who were involved with identifying
um Pills and and so on and so forth
through a through a a
graphical recognition system
and uh he brought some Spice gold and
some spice Diamond to herbal incense
products and would like uh he said he'd
like to run them on annual orbitrap
systems to see what uh what we could
find
um in the analysis we actually
identified jwh 18 and something called
cp47497 which is what the uh the
austrians and the Germans had found a
few months earlier
generically these things are have called
are called synthetic cannabinoid
receptor agonists or
um scars and I'll be referring to these
as scars through the rest of the talk
so the spice Diamond product that we
tested in 2009
um gave this very large Peak here at
um about five minutes on our lcms run
and it actually had an elemental
composition of c24 h23 no which was
consistent with jwh18 that had been
reported at the end of 2008. this is the
ms-2 spectrum that we generated and
you'll see that this is very similar to
the data that was produced by the um the
austrians and the Germans on on this
particular compound and there's the only
difference of course being that we're
using accurate mass as opposed to
nominal Mass
so what is jwh18 it was first
synthesized in 1995 by John W Huffman's
group in Clemson University in the USA
to study drug structure cell receptor
relationships are you looking at how
drugs interacted with the drug receptors
it's never been tested formally in
humans as a normal drug substance would
be and it's apparently five times more
potent than THC and that's backed up by
some of the receptor-based assays that
have been developed more recently to
test for these types of things
structurally it's very dissimilar to THC
which is the main active ingredient in
cannabis
it's now illegal in many
this slide shows a brief history of
synthetic cannabinoids in the UK and
cp47497 was around very early on jwh 18
at the same time but then over the last
13 years or so the the main the main
synthetic cannabinoids have basically
maintained the same kind of structure
we've got a core of either an indole or
an indosol moiety and
there are usually
um alcohol side chains which are either
fluorinated or non-fluorinated sometimes
there's a cyclic group on the on the
side chain
um the functional groups in the in the
in the in the other position on the
molecule
um adamantyl groups
um you've got a
um
an amino acid on here and lots of amino
acid type
um derivatives on on on on on this
particular part of the molecule
so where have they come from
um first of all jwh 18 actually came
from some of Huffman's work in in the
scientific literature
um various compounds over the years have
been worked on as alternatives to
cannabis as treatment for pain
and obviously patents have been filed
for those and they are public access
documents so people have been pulling
these things out and more recently
um there have been some truly designer
synthetic cannabinoids produced in an
attempt to evade legislation as most
legislation
released up till recently have been
based on on defined structures of
compounds so it only takes a slight
modification to to make the compounds
legal again until the legislation
catches up and Huffman actually
published a paper
where he's uh he's talking about
hijacking of basic research I.E people
using his research to uh to generate
these particularly nasty compounds
so what are the effects of scars on the
human the effects are believed to be
mediated through CB1 and CB2 receptors
these receptors cell receptors actually
affect multiple systems in the human
body including the central nervous
system respiratory cardiovascular and
immune systems
scars are actually total agonists for
these receptors THC
is a partial Agonist if you remember THC
is is the react the active ingredient in
cannabis
some Scrolls and metabolites
tend to have stronger affinities
receptors than THC and this leads to
Greater potency and longer duration of
effects
scroll-related deaths are actually from
the acute toxicity stroke heart attack
and suicide
um there is more information around
cause of death from synthetic
cannabinoids now than they used to be
and we look down the list here there's a
these things seem to have
a major effect on many systems within
the body
so over the period of 2008 to 2019
um looking across Europe these are
figures presented by the European
monitoring centers for drugs and drug
addiction and you'll see that in 2008 we
just had a handful of synthetic
cannabinoids but they grew to a peak
around 2012 and 2013 where we were
seeing probably 30 or more different
compounds each year and and these have
tailed off to um to really sort of less
than 10 a year as we head towards 2020
but we find more of the individual fines
it's not suggesting that the uh that the
total number of synthetic cannabinoids
have have dropped it's just that the
variation has reduced
and if you look at this data here this
is from from our lab and these are the
findings that we've um we've we've
identified over the last six or seven
years
um
and all of these findings represent
um the uh major scar findings as
percentage of the quarterly totals
detected so if you look here this was
actually a compound called five fluoro
akb48 and that was really nearly 100 of
our findings in sort of 2013 2014 and
you'll see the duration of um of these
things on the market is is usually
around 18 to 24 months and there are
probably two or three main ones at any
point in time
the most common one at the moment is
something called mdmb foreign panaca
which is uh you know making up probably
about
um about 65 of our our findings but
there are these newer compounds coming
online here called four flow mdmb bicker
for fluoro a butinacara and ADB butanaca
that uh that are starting to lift off
and they may well replace over the next
year or so mdmb flooring panaca as the
the most prevalent in the UK
foreign
so how do we actually test for synthetic
cannabinoids we have a variety of
extraction methods for each type of
motorist that we're trying to extract
synthetic cannabinoids from
um
so once we prepared a sample we analyze
the sample down the exactly the same
methodology on a q exactive
and we have an LC method which is based
on an acetic acid methanol gradient and
it's quite a fast runtime we're looking
at five and a half minute acquisition
time
it's impositive electoral spray and the
workflow itself on there the acquisition
workflow consists of full scan and full
scan online fragmentation and we
searched this data against an accurate
Mass database containing over a thousand
a thousand squares
and we also run a data dependent Ms the
two
um
workflow within the method and this is
initiated from an inclusion list that is
generated from our accurate Mass
database and we use a tolerance of plus
or minus two millidaltons to fire off
the MS to the two scans
and our data processing is on trace
finder
in order to describe the workflow in
more detail I'm going to present data on
mdmb4 in panaca which is currently a
significant problem in many parts of the
world
on the slide you'll see reports from
both the European Monitoring Center for
drugs and drug addiction and the World
Health Organization and this highlights
really the the global importance of of
this particular drug
so the first two elements of the
analytical workflow on the QX active a
full scan and all Iron fragmentation aif
the full scan element runs scanning from
200 to 500
um Daltons and the aif is from 80 to 500
and as you see here this is an extracted
our enchromatic RAM for NDM before in
panaca with a nice Peak here and this is
the all-line fragmentation
extracted ichromatogram for the major
fragment iron for mdmb foreign finacure
in this second Peak here is actually the
metabolite which fragments in the same
way and gives the um gives the same
major fragment time
so all of our targeted compound data is
is held in an accurate Mass data
processing database and you can see here
all the entries for mdmb4 in panaca and
all you do basically is put in the
molecular formula and it will calculate
the extracted mass and based on the
adduct and the polarity you're using and
here we have the retention time and
there are various other parameters
around various thresholds for data
processing purposes
you can export the information from the
accurate Mass database to an inclusion
list and our inclusion list has got over
a thousand analytes and this is
generated directly from the accurate
Mass database and here you see the the
information in the inclusion list so
there are about a thousand lines in here
and this is the accurate mass of mdmb4
in panaca and um this is what the
instrument will use when it's doing data
dependent Ms to the two
foreign so moving on to the type of data
that we see for a data dependent Ms to
the two all these lines are
um Ms the two events that have been
initiated
um through the use of the inclusion list
and the data has been recorded in the in
the data file and uh this Peak at 4.35
has a scan associated with it and this
is a fairly good Mass Spectrum of mgmb
foreign panaca
we can visualize the data that's been
acquired for a single sample using trace
finder the peak in the bottom left-hand
corner is extracted line chromatogram
for the uh for the full scan element of
of the sample and this is
um the correct Peak for mdmb foreign
panaca this is the fragment ion again
generated from the data dependent msms
and this is a match of um against the
library that we've created in the house
this is a spectrum from the library this
is a spectrum from the sample and as you
can see there's a very very good match
for mdmb foreign panaca
foreign
so blowing that up again you'll see
there is a there is a very good match
here if you look at the accuracy of the
masses here and the relative abundancies
we actually use an energy spread as that
gives a very good um high and low mass
mass spectrum and it tends to be more
information Rich than just a single
energy
um used for for fragmentation purposes
as I said earlier we're currently seeing
a lot of mdmb foreign panaca but we've
also started to detect this compound
here called four fluoroa butanaka and
it's actually a four fluoro version of 5
fluoro akb48 which is if you recall the
the synthetic cannabinoid that was most
prevalent about sort of
2014-15 time
ADB butanaca is a is a
a butyl synthetic cannabinoid very
similar to in that respect to the four
fluoride butanaca and uh four floor mdmb
bicker is a four fluoro version of five
fluoro mdme picker which was a another
major synthetic cannabinoid for us in
about 2018. so these are all
modifications of previous drug compounds
foreign so this is a urine sample that
tested positive for four fluoroa
butaneca and as you can see through the
use of extracted iron chromatograms for
potential metabolites who've identified
a whole range of of compounds most of
these are hydroxylated in various
positions there's a butanoic acid
metabolite and actually there's the the
most common generally
metabolite in
fluoroalkyl compounds is this despera
hydroxy compound
so if you look at the metabolite here
we're starting with the parent compound
and we're seeing replacement of the
fluorine with with the hydroxy group we
sign hydroxylation in the Adamantite and
moiety and we're seeing combinations of
these things as well and there's also a
metabolite um through hydroxylation here
and hydroxylation on the adamantile
so these are mass Spectra for
metabolites of for fluorobutanaka in the
in disulfuric fluorobutar moiety as you
can see the predominant ion in all these
Mass Spectra are is the adamantal
fragments which is a 135 ion and it's
very hard to tell them apart other than
the precursor iron
likewise metabolism the adamant are
moiety you're seeing a a change from the
135 to the ones 151 and
um the dihydroxy is actually seeing that
151 going to the 167 here once again um
because we're using the energy spread
we're actually seeing some parent iron
as well which helps in identification
so the other compound that I mentioned
earlier is a as a newish compound is ADB
butanaca um this isn't as widely
metabolized and the main metabolite here
is this um is basically it's an
oxidative deamination product and we
also see hydroxylations in both the
endosol ring and the butyl side chain
ADP butaneca is another one of the new
compounds that we're seeing parent
compound you can see gives a a major Ion
at 201 oxidative deamination actually
really doesn't change a great deal here
other than the precursor iron obviously
changes
um hydroxylation on the endosal moiety
gives a shift from 201 to 217 and
actually hydroxy on the butane moiety
um that means that the 161 that you see
on the indosol
um
hydroxylation it remains as 145 because
the hydroxylation is occurring on the
butane
so hot off the press so to speak
um this is something that's been going
on quite a lot in the USA um gummies are
basically sweets uh gummy bears is where
it originates from
um they've been found to contain CBD
which is uh a product coming from
marijuana and
um more recently they've been found to
contain synthetic cannabinoid receptor
agonists this is a sample that we got in
the UK from from a forensic seizure and
we tested it through our system
so when we looked at the data from the
gummy extraction we could see that there
is a peak largest Peak here at 4.15 and
the aif data showed a very large iron
232.1127 which is uh indicative of a
range of synthetic cannabinoids
um the elemental composition has
confirmed here
we went and then did Target Ms the two
to generate a decent Ms to two spectrum
and once again we matched up with the
aif data with a 232 iron
the Mass Spectrum from the sample was
similar to five fluoro mdmb picker but
the precursor Mass was a methyl group
bigger
this suggested that the lightly compound
was actually five fluoro edmb picker
this was confirmed using NMR
and this really is hot off the press
this is a report from our recent bank
holiday weekend where children had been
taken to hospital after eating sweets
and it seems as though they contain
cannabis I wonder if these actually
contain synthetic cannabinoid receptor
agonists as this seems to be fairly
consistent with what we're seeing in our
forensic sample
so in summary
um we've seen that scars keep evolving
we have got robust high resolution mass
workflows that enable us to keep up with
new compounds new compounds are
currently emerging that will replace
mgmb4ing panacher over the next few
months and this seems to be a a cycle of
about 18 to 24 months um when a when a
new compound will stay around and we
have actually just seen new ways in
consuming scars that have got uh major
dangers for for children especially at
this particular moment